[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de pas
fait si vous voulez gagner de l'argent
fait des paris fait des paris sur les
sujets que nous allons aborder dans
cette émission et je serais vous je
parierais sur le coronavirus parce que
tout le monde en parle n'y a pas de
raison chrono phase ne fasse pas de nous
non plus et pour en parler ben and
german bezina duclair coup comment ça va
bien bien vous n'avez je suis séparé non
voilà on va d'abord demandé à bulletin
de santé avec saint jean baptiste du
clec j'ai vu non vous n'êtes pas mouche
et vous n'êtes pas par plus personne ne
me dit bonjour voilà bah oui stéphane
mensonge ou pas de bise pas de bilan
c'est frustrant on s'est appelé la main
on s'aime plus donc c'est même plus oui
non mais c'est un on a des problèmes
c'est un des problèmes de de cette
maladie c'est quand même plus l'autre
mais vite aux gens fiables je dis
bonjour ça va très bien j'ai pas dis je
n'ai pas dit que vous êtes m 2 couverts
de droit public et de science politique
pareil pareil presse c'est encore c'est
dingue
ses fans manceau pourrait profiter très
commun ici des honoraires mon petit vous
êtes de plus anciens d'entre nous fait
pas du g7 village et jean pierre davot
dit vous êtes toujours éditeur parce que
malgré le coroner virus alors on ne va
plus au cinéma
oui en plus au théâtre j'ai un peu peur
que les gens désertent librairie et j'ai
un peu peur mais c'est l'enfer c'est
bizarrement dans le quartier des crises
comme ça c'est arrivé quand tv par
exemple à la guerre du golfe les gens à
acheter moins de livres living rêver
parce que c'est pas parce que les gens
qui veulent être informés que de ce qui
les préoccupe à cet instant la france
étaient en panne virus par abeilles
serait tort la seule chose qu'ils
achètent pour l'instant c'est la peste
paraît qu'il avait un carton absolu mais
bon après la peste ils peuvent dire ça
avec de camus et donc les crimes a
corsica de stéphane hawks il habitait en
corse pendant trois ans il a travaillé
habitait encore sont en trois ans et
s'il a pondu ce roman qui est assez
exceptionnel trépidant violent
une lutte entre une mafieux un parrain
corse dominique casanova dit doux mais
voilà exactement vous d'être très bien
et une bande rivale d'origine des fins
peu du 9-3 et qui demande d' arabes qui
veut prendre place et épié en corse
donc c'est devenu une lutte entre les
deux et l'originalité du fc tient pas
tant là dedans que très très bien
raconté très bien imaginer mais dans le
fait que ce truand d'oumé et finalement
très amoureux de sa femme et que c'était
un truand au grand coeur pour ce qui
concerne sa femme pas pour ce qui
concerne mais la bande à rami veut lui
piquer sa place mais en tout cas avec sa
famille les plus de l'économie reprend
la balle et corse oui mais je pense
qu'il vente à savoir travailler alors
après les enfants sur les descendants de
lucien bonaparte voilà dirais donc me
connaissait voilà ça c'est mieux que
nous voilà la mentalité c'est très bien
ça d'une bonne une bonne image de la
corse paysages corses
et puis depuis de la truanderie corps
soit qu'il existait dans lequel ils sont
une sorte de spécialité quand même oui
il ya ils savent bien faire ça chacun
son truc et beckwith et le score était
il ya beaucoup de policiers si oui j'ai
alors après parme il ya même bien même
des interactions l'autre oui quand on
est grand on a le choix aux policiers
c'est un peu partout comme ça et
maintenant celui là pourquoi y ait dans
la police il heurte un peu has been aux
familles des choix le gars qui s'est
trompé de porte cabanon ça c'est le
recrutement la toile y sommes c'est
ballot il omet de conférence c'est
pourquoi à chaque fois qu'on parle de la
corse on est toujours un peu
caricaturaux mais parce qu'on adore ça
on est dans une autre vie évidemment
voilà c'est que c'est trop d'amour qui
s'exprime c'est manger ses symboles oui
vous êtes marié avec les charentais oui
et je me sens très mal
et oui mais vous avez ségolène royal
donc non goûter des choses
extraordinaires ouvrir la sauver de
marais poitevin oui oui de la
construction d'une autoroute eux est
classé grand parc national chez l'humain
on parle d'écologie est là elle a fait
classer le chabichou en a aussi mais la
passerelle à charentaise dont j'ai
appris qu'elle honore disparités alors
elles n'ont ya une reprise ni norbert
oui oui je l'espère parce que ça c'est
un drame mais parce que ton stock à fin
mai non mais j'ai un stop j'ai constitué
mon style c'est intéressant comme
mission
jean pelle et desserrant n'oubiez on
peut on peut se dire bonjour est ce
sérieux maintenant apparemment ça ne
risque rien mais quoique parce que des
rumeurs pour l eau est alors vous savez
qu'on ne peut pas embrasser son coude
on peut se moucher dans son buzz ou chez
oui c'est impossible
exact leschi par exemple les chutes en
coude et une fois c'est impossible
voilà sauf alors lucien bonaparte y
serait arrivé mais il faut qu'ils se
blessent absolue et bien je vous
demander d'être grave d'être sérieux et
d'être précis puisque nous allons avoir
des l'événement c'est la france face au
virus peut-être que nous sommes français
du gilbert qui savent dans une époque de
collapse au logis c'est-à-dire de 2,2 en
croit la fin du monde c'est pour ça que
nous sommes très détendus ces sites et
roger gicquel oui roger gicquel roger
gicquel a fait faire plusieurs mois la
voilà la france a peur c'était
exactement c'était ça c'était au moment
de la faire patrick henry exo rappeler 1
s'était fait un autre via séoul tenais
je tenais bien
plus figurez-vous un jeu pour vous
raconter une histoire
c'est à dire n'importe quoi c'est
évidemment il n'était pas une blague
honnête mais un jour j'étais à radio
france et est quelqu'un arrive dans mon
dos eelv et orangé et c'était sa cousine
ou sa belle soeur kim avait confondu
avec roger gicquel et que je peux je le
tiens quelqu'un dans la voix et alors
j'étais vexé parce que j'avais quand
même temps nous vint enfin et je voulais
refaire la france a peur c'était
l'époque ses disques ont amené aux
ouvrir le devenu combattant
et alors c'était là c'était l'époque où
le 21 commencer par un éditorial le
journal de 20 heures c'est à dire qu'il
durait à peu près de 3 3 4 minutes
d'élite au coin c'était qu'on ne ferait
plus aujourd'hui on vous dit il faut
aller beaucoup plus vite
alors y'a pas des petits taurian parce
que nous allons directement de
l'événement comme vous n'avez plus sa
part dans le sujet faisait alors c'est
vrai que j'ai vu une statistique évaporé
80% des informations qui sont diffusées
aujourd'hui ont trait aux coronavirus ce
qui est assez amusant parce qu'on sait
pas grand chose au fond enfin si l'on
sait des choses c'est pas de choses je
ne sais pas en tout cas les rumeurs il
ya deux tours à lyon du mélange à l'air
de l'air de tout savoir sur tous les
réseaux sociaux tout le monde absolument
experts les gens sont là pour dire le
gouvernement a tort le gouvernement de
faire ça avant lors il devrait faire ça
nicolas dupont aignan qui met le masque
à l'envers
li voilà la presse fasse baisser au même
endroit c'est quand même mieux non enfin
et et oui et condamne l' amateurisme je
crois du pouvoir mais toujours avec une
très grande classe toujours riche
voulons surtout pas les gens non et
c'est ça qui est terrible je crois avec
les médias avec peut-être certains
politiques c'est que on a l'impression
qu'il ya un crise de nerfs un affolement
général de la population
quelqu'un dise et sio si on faisait le
compte chaque fois des morts de grippe
chaque fois qu'il vient à mort si on
faisait un nom n'arrêterai pas et
courses explique salah tout petit peu
différent parce que la grippe tout le
monde tout le monde sur cet argument dix
ans la grippe fait entre cinq et sept
mille morts par an en france
mais en fait c'est pas tout à fait vrai
parce que la grippe directement fait 500
morts par an et après les autres oui des
gens qui développent c'est le matelas
parce qu'ils ont été affaiblis par
l'appareil c'est complètement différent
le coran d'un virus lui c'est
directement la maladie qui déclenche la
mort voilà mais bon c'est pas pour ça
qu'il faut non plus paniquer donc c'est
peut-être une façon de régler le
problème des retraites de façon
définitive
et oui ok mais ce qui est pas est-ce
qu'il ya pas quand même derrière tout ça
le le pouvoir se protègent là dessus une
sorte de principe de précaution principe
de prévention ont dit de plus en plus
fort qui fait que tout pouvoir a peur
d'être attaqués si jamais il n'avait pas
pris les mesures qui sont des essais et
d'eau on prend des précautions
absolument incroyable non il ya
certainement de cela on a vu la gestion
de la canicule
en juin de cette année où on a reporté
les épreuves du brevet donc oui oui je
crois que ce qu'il est un mauvais
souvenir
en effet je crois qu'on attend beaucoup
de choses du gouvernement maintenant
qu'il nous protège de quelque chose que
lui même ne maîtrise pas forcément et du
coup ça donne forcément des actions
positives assez paradoxal parce que au
fond on ne sait pas bien ce qu'on peut
attendre de nos gouvernants dans ces
moments là eux mêmes ne sont pas
forcément tous médecins
donc je crois que c'est assez difficile
de savoir comment il faudrait réagir
d'un état à l'autre d'ailleurs la
gestion et pas du tout la même
mais moi j'ai l'impression que ce virus
il a du succès parce qu'il a un petit
peu tous les instruments du polar quand
il vient de l'étranger
on ne sait pas comment ils évoluent on a
le sentiment de doha après il ya un
espèce de feuilleton autour de susan
boyle c'est ça qui est bon sens
justement voilà peut-être ce que disent
les essieux qui n'a pas été encore oui
pas boxer qui est plutôt donc une fois
coincé mais ça c'est vrai si jeune c'est
vrai qu'on demande aux chercheurs d d d
avis définitif sur des choses qui
découvrent brook l'enceinte expliqué ce
qui est curieux si ces deux côtés enfin
pour répondre à votre question de je
pense qu'on est dans une société on
n'accepte plus loin de risques donc ils
vont veut absolument que tous soient
verrouillées validé faut que le
gouvernement protège tout le monde nous
dise comment il faut se laver les mains
comment il faisait ce qu'il faut faire
et c'est donc il ya un côté infantile
dans la population qui est qui
capitalise pas moi non cela plus
généralement ça va probablement enrayer
la prochaine épidémie de gastro-entérite
si les gens apprennent à se laver les
mains ça c'est plutôt positif
c'est positif qui face à ces mesures de
prévention que les gens soient bien
informés mais ce que je trouve dommage
mais ça c'est pas une crise que je ferai
à l'endroit du gouvernement c'est plutôt
au niveau des médias qui justement nous
explique pas en fait les raisons pour
lesquelles on prend bien le fait de se
laver les mains ce genre de choses est
par exemple jeu j'ai en mémoire ces
pauvres commerçants qui étaient les
registres le matin qui avait qui
s'étaient réunis sur le sur le marché on
leur dit en en quelques minutes qu'il
faut il faut remballer il faut rentrer
chez eux alors que c'est si tu as
inquiété dans l'oise
alors qu ensuite chacun pouvait aller au
supermarché pour aller faire de l'île
verte à l'écran pas ou alors la mesure
des cires plus de 5000 il faut pas mais
alors après on comprend pas ce niveau
des transports en commun donc moi il ya
certainement une cohérence dans tout ça
mais faudrait qu'on puisse expliquer en
fait pourquoi ceci dans un cas et
pourquoi pas s'essayer dans l'autre il
est
expliqué oui c'est totalement idiot mais
il ya un autre gars de 4999 5000 âmes
après la reprise mais il faut bien il
faut bien une limite alors ils ont
choisi 5000 mais hazard tourne
aujourd'hui c'est le fils bien au delà
il ya du monde mais à 5000 on est
conscients les étudiants vous avez cette
mine non dans un amphithéâtre de 5000
places
cela s'est installé les matchs de foot
par exemple sont pas tous animés on
refuse du monde
enfin en france et est par exemple
hier elle a eu la victoire de
saint-etienne demi-finale et de les
faire des verts mais bien sûr il ya
trente mille personnes qui se sont
précipités après sur le terrain
entourant l'un des joueurs notamment
pour la il ya un petit risque quant à
lui risque pour lui ça veut le salon du
livre a été annulée série l'italienne
car c'est ça c'est pas parce qu'on peut
aborder aussi les conséquences
économiques ce parce que ça c'est plus
grave mais ça c'est vraiment quand même
énorme pour les pour les éditeurs vous
pouvez laisser un gros manque à gagner
c'est un moment de rencontre avec
beaucoup de gens y viennent de toute la
france et qui n'est pas seulement de
paris qui viennent de l'étranger qu'ils
découvrent les les maisons d'édition qui
découvre les auteurs qui venait
dédicacer
et voilà donc ça c'est effectivement et
quand on dit que c'est annulé ça veut
dire que ce n'est pas reportée c'est
vraiment socialisme c'est reporté à 2021
donc à une prochaine
c'est vraiment là que j'ai vraiment
délais donc c'est un peu très gênant
parce qu'on peut imaginer beaucoup de
salons ou s'ils vont se marrer théorie
on peut on peut craindre aussi une crise
économique on va
des conséquences économiques très forte
dans un opérateur économique c'est déjà
le cas oui absolument
lundi 18 le nouveau va vendre moins de
clients la bourse les avions j'en ai la
merde pour les avions enfin pour les
transports aériens est énorme et vous
faut mais c'est ça le fil rouge du
gouvernement finalement c'est à dire que
on nous interdit d'aller au théâtre on
interdit les grandes roues désert c'est
un petit peu d'aller vers des
regroupements donc les gens sortent
moins et nra mais finalement on va tous
travailler
donc économiquement le fil rouge des
actions c'est d'essayer de en fait de
montrer qu'on agit sur des actions
ponctuelles qui finalement
économiquement perdent relativement peu
pour essayer de continuer à inciter les
gens à aller travailler mais il ya une
vraie psychose qui est en train de
s'installer c'est à dire que finalement
les gens ont le sentiment que si la
communication gouvernementale est à ce
point là alarmiste pourquoi finalement
ne tapais que sur des mesures aussi
sectorielle il faudrait dans ce cas là
qu'on soit dans un stade iii avec
finalement leur manière ils jouent tous
on y arrive en mairie mais
économiquement là ça fait quand même
trois jours qui viennent au stade
3 évidemment on voit dis pas que par
l'équipement des mesures radicales
beaucoup plus radical que les dons dont
la fermeture des universités alors
vermeer et des universités européennes
oui c'est ça c'est triste là par exemple
puisque vous enseigner des uns les
autres
vous constatez non il ya de
l'absentéisme dans les amphis ou pas
pour l'instant leur moi j'ai pas j'ai eu
l'amphi l'amphithéâtre de première année
hier qu'ils sont 1 300 g pas constaté
d'une absence notable
par contre voici l'inquiète c'est le cd
les c'est à dire que bon j'ai bon espoir
que tous les cours vont se dérouler
jusqu'à la fin fin du mois mais c'est en
revanche pour les examens qui sont fixés
en mai donc c'est à peu près dans un an
deux mois et demi j'espère et là c'est
ma crainte parce que autant on peut
trouver des mesures de substitution pour
donner des cours à distance mais par
contre pour faire les examens à distance
ça c'est également impossible donc ça
c'est ça c'est une vraie crainte parce
qu autant je peux comprendre qu'on
puisse loupé un théâtre où quelques
sages mais c'est un vrai problème le
problème c'est plus embêtant pour les
écrits ou pour les écrits mais aussi
pour les oraux pour les estimations ils
sont massés dans le voile dans les
amphithéâtres
oui oui mais il faut aussi partant il
faut y avait mais il faut aussi pouvoir
contrôler l'identité des étudiants c'est
vrai que oui peut-être peut-être des
attributs religieux qui sont sur une
bonne prévention canton
ces années et alors il ya des choses à
plus ou moins plus ou moins bonnes
chauffes a qui arrivent là dessus vous
en parlez de céleste est lié à la peur
de l'autre quand même la stigmatisation
notamment des asiatiques il faut pas
beaucoup de choses pour que cette peur
xénophobie c'est épouvantable oui j'ai
même des j'entendais l'autre jour que
des gens ne mangent plus dans des
restaurants asiatiques ne consomme plus
de nems éclats et que la bière corona et
que l'action dévissé nature davis etc
on disait ça en plaisantant mais c'est
arrivé dérivés les cds 25 amusant c'est
une chaîne de supermarchés en belgique
qui met deux corps en a acheté une mort
subite offert ça c'était vrai ça c'est
très bien c'est vrai que d'amour
non mais c'est vrai que la
stigmatisation ccc comme on se disait au
début il brosse c'est vrai que se dire
bonjour sens toucher son on n'a pas
l'habitude dans cette option est une
barrière vis-à-vis nos questions nous
mêmes dans notre culture on a plutôt
tendance à se toucher leur bon c'est
plutôt pas bien pour des histoires oui
messieurs soir sanitaire de santé
publique
mais il ya bien d'autres cultures on ne
se touchent pas le ils se saluent
raisonnablement voilà dans la culture
britannique d'aller lui on ne seront ne
se touchent surtout pas et nous on n'a
pas l'habitude on n'est pas habitués
comme si nous manquait quelque chose
comme cela c'est canal poli option ne
sait mais plus patrice besse est comme
si on suit les mémés mais c'est
peut-être pas fou de dire ça peut-être
qu'on ne va plus et mais on ne sourit
plus non pas nous je parle pas de nous
oui mais
c'est à dire ne pas aimer l'autre n'ont
cessé sa dégustation de la tombola ou
des jeux les martinique et de guadeloupe
y dom rom si je puis me permets
d'endroits où il est en plus des thèmes
et les roms c'est toi la région de messi
fusée moi ça ça rejoint sa précision un
rappel au règlement auquel doit donc
dans les deux hommes voilà tous les deux
et ils ont une robe mondiaux je sais
bien
ils ont refusé l'accès à des italiens
quand même c'est vrai mais avec violence
mais les français commencent à être
ostracisé je crois que c'est israël qui
a fermé c'est la russe et la vente est
l'inconvénient c'est que comme le virus
se fiche des nationalités finalement
vain ce week en fait on a refusé tout le
monde ce samedi est bien là elle a juste
que par le seco cas cependant cessé les
chinois qui eux qui ont inventé le virus
et le virus leurs problèmes ils refusent
que les français je veux que les gens
qui viennent de franchir réimportent à
me le jazz saison saisissante de vaincre
chez eux donc oui nous faudrait une
bonne dictature mais ça c'est une chose
et puis il ya aussi une idéologie qui
est arrivé là dessus sur la
mondialisation
on a entendu des politiques mais comme
on ne forme pas de frontière et en même
temps alors c'est amusant parce qu'il ya
des gens qui disent vas la
mondialisation c'est pas elle qui a
porté le virus mais c'est peut-être elle
qui va nous sauver puisque les médecins
dans le monde entier collaborent et et
ils vont peut-être trouver voilà où le
vaccin ou là où la façon de soigner le
virus et le mali mais c'est vrai ça
laisse une impression de l'extrême
proximité
on est tous dans le village planète oui
oui ça date limite et on a là encore
plus conscience dans ce genre de
situation je trouve qu'il est très
intéressant aussi je trouve ça me ça
monte aussi de dépendance vis-à-vis de
la chine économiquement sur beaucoup de
produits notamment des médicaments
s'aperçoit quasiment plus aucun
médicament des fabriques et en europe et
que là on est lancé
et voilà donc ce que ça ça veut
peut-être provoqué un certain
rééquilibrage une re re localisation qui
sera pas le ministre et l'économie et
donc c'est l'horaire a commencé à dire
voilà il n'y a aucune raison que des
médicaments
en chine on doit pouvoir le faire
nous-mêmes moche c'est bien qu'ils aient
finalement sa prise de conscience sur la
dépendance que crée cette modernisation
néanmoins après je pense qu'il faut pas
en arriver à jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain ce qui est un petit peu en train de
se passer à l'heure actuelle c'est qu'on
nous a beaucoup incité on a dit notre
jeunesse était enfin européenne
globe-trotter on a eu des vols à moins
de 20 euros pour pour montrer à quel
point le monde était un petit village et
finalement aujourd'hui on nous y voilà
mon dieu on n'a pas vu les risques de
tout cela c'est profondément choisi
économiquement culturellement depuis des
années donc voilà ne retirons pas tout
ce qu'on a tiré comme vertu de cela tout
en se rendant compte que finalement il
ya quand même des excès qui la
mériteraient d'être contrôlés mais ça
fait des années que certains partis
politiques le disent et que certains
politiques ne s'en rendent même plus
compte
économiquement on a une dépendance qui
est absolue donc il ya peut-être un
moment où il faudra réfléchir là dessus
et si c'est ce moment là pourquoi pas et
la croissance qui est beau et aux dires
de chine
il pourrait y avoir une décroissance qui
vivra l'os il se dessine aujourd'hui on
paye un petit effet positif c'est la
pollution qui baissent considérablement
oui donc là il ya d une photo d
saisissante que moi de brefs usines -
une photo prise par la nasa rimer cd de
la chine avant et pendant qu'on avait la
tâche de pollution le nuage de pollution
a quasiment disparu nous inviter cesse
la pollution disparaît on va peut-être
expérimentait la décroissance
économiquement on y réfléchit depuis des
années ces raisons et bien sûr les
indicateurs de décroissance
pourquoi pas est ce que je vous demande
et c'est très sérieusement il répondra
rapidement est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est la fin du monde non mais non on
s'en fout c'est tout tout tout va bien
orienté ces vols ne survécut aussi les
autres voitures dit ça parce qu'il ya eu
alors il y avait vous savez c'est
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux enfin
ça y est il ya tellement de rumeurs
tellement de bêtises qu'ils les
glaciologues et g et pardonnez moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé aussi les plates east oui
ça n'est pas dans votre ordre du jour
patrice mais les pnjs et ceux qui n'ont
ils entendent démontrer que la terre est
plate
je suis dit si tu es absolument c'est un
leader des plates de l'idheap christ fut
prêté au val mais enfin bon c'est une
scission oui c'est vrai que oui une
mauvaise période pour les plates east
bon on a fait voilà évidemment pour
discuter pendant pendant des heures et
des heures et est de toute façon comme
la situation évolue d'heure en heure de
jour en jour donc ce qu'on a dit
aujourd'hui sera sans doute peut-être
faut demain je ne sais pas on verra bien
où même peut-être nouvelle bulle a
besoin d'y aller ça plus les gens qui
font des stocks dans les magasins
ah oui d'ecstasy que comportement dès
que le risque est bien de chine et que
les pattes ça vient d'italie
donc c'est dans la meilleure façon que
ce soit 10 du cours un pur et alors j'ai
lu parce que sa façon au pape
j'ai lu et j'en parlais aux étudiants le
feu soir que les stocks d'huile aussi
elles étaient des piliers dans certaines
grandes surfaces
donc c'est un cocktail assez détonnant
je sais il faut mettre une goutte
d'huile quand vous faites ça ça je joue
un jeune alors hervé this on discute des
fellations gisement tard il est arrêté
mais culturellement sur les drogues non
parce que les sur les normes c'est pas
des balles sur le corps au navire use de
tous est important de norohna virus sont
pas arrivés sur lui l'ont déçu et c'est
un universitaire qui vous le dit mais
culturellement a culturellement vite le
maître après
non non non non non non mais tout cela
pour dire que les stock d'huile
diminuent d'heure en heure et ça je
m'interroge
voilà les gens vont être re plus chez
eux à ouvrir leurs conserves et faire
cuire leurs pâtes et boire de l'huile
est ce que c'est ça finalement
le paysage de la fin du monde autour
d'une bouteille du jeu c'est triste
d'être ici c'est si c'est le message
qu'il faut leur donner c'est dévalisé
les rayons de 20 du coup ça s'appelle
bien passé ça me paraît que vous boire
chaud c'est peu de cannelle lefebvre à 7
degrés donc 9 h à 17 h ou alors qu'on
était à l'époque l'huile avec un pot de
kamel aouis moi j'aime bien peu de
cannelle kucera vainqueur vêtissent
avait montré que
messi s'est montré qu'il fallait pas
mettre de moutarde dans la bayonnaise
sinon ça ne s'appelle pas une mayonnaise
allait nous l'avait dit écoutez moi j'ai
remis d'abord c'est le frère je sais
votre concert d'isabelle this injustice
qui est aussi lui soit de versailles et
c'est un très grand scientifique
absolument c'est le sait le père de
commandement appelle ça de la visite
médicale chinoise est chimérique
organismes et si on dit la gastronomie
la cuisine moléculaire oui je crois que
c'est la cuisine moléculaire
eh bien ces contrôles édition la france
a peur la france a peur du roi la
françafrique
la france a peur les journées partisans
est ce que la france a peur du 49 3
c'est la polémique en franc parler dans
un instant c'est la semaine alors oui
même en chine a dit jean luc mélenchon
on n'a pas recours au khroub str mairie
il ya un truc depuis lost ou merlus de
communication d'abord craint d'abord il
faudrait dire l'article 49 alinéa 3
séances
quand vous faites gérer nos droits
constitutionnels vous dites plutôt sage
et lors des gaines de 49 tous les
journaux l'impression qu'il ya un type
avec une kalachnikov cédant vocabulaire
même parce qu'on connaît qu'on était sur
les gicquel en à un éminent collègue
jean gicquel qui qui qualifie le 49-3 de
la grosse paire ce week-end
cc c'est là on peut le commenter comme
ça c'est la grosse bertha en effet c'est
vrai que celle arme absolue du
parlementarisme rationalisé la vème
république c'est un peu sa petite c'est
sa french touch en fait de la
constituent d'autres fois il y aurait
l'article 16 je sais plus s'il est
toujours en vigueur mais quelqu'un plus
été appliquée depuis très longtemps
quand même plus de gaulle 1 mais
l'article 16 a dit c'était quand même ce
côté un peu entre guillemets -
républicains face et c'est le gros tous
les pouvoirs au chef de l'état toi tu ne
feras tu républicaine les dictatures au
sens romain et terme tout contrôle du
conseil visible de ces régions des
réunions et s'il me semble des
assemblées ou sinon effectivement un peu
près 10 ou très bas c'était c'était
l'article 16 autrefois c'était l'article
et qui a été remplacé ne sont pas encore
9,3
non assène c'est pas du tout la même
pardon non non dans l'image dans
l'imaginaire de deux neveux juste skier
république un baraquement un quart des
discours politiques
alors c'est peut-être de bonne guerre
mais enfin ça n'a rien à voir rien à
rien avoir du tout non mais mais dans
l'imaginaire dans l'église à sion enfin
l'alinéa 3 de l'article 49 il a été
utilisé que 4 80 x 28 x d'autres mots
qui nous donc on a fait beaucoup par
michel regardes tu étais un dictateur
qui se sent ni même en chine et non pas
de michel renquin qui se permet de
critiquer mais voilà je les ai je les
utiliser mais c'est un aveu d'échec
mais si vous voyez leur il fallait alors
oui il laissait ses raisonnements extra
duels on peut l'utiliser mais pas pour
les retraites alors il faut savoir qu'en
plus cela l'utilisation de françois
hollande elle est assez intéressant
parce que c'est six fois dont deux fois
trois en réalité c'est à dire qu'à
chaque lecture des deux textes sur
lequel il a fait adopter la loi travail
et la loi macron avant macron est
précisément à chaque lecture le 49-3
avait été dégainée donc c'est dire à
quel point pour le coup le ct une
utilisation presse la plus autoritaire
qu'on a eu toute la vème république il
n'y a même pas eu une seule fenêtre
d'amendements pour le parlement sur
cette fois-là 1041 mila minh man ça
s'appelle de l'obstruction c'est-à-dire
et assumer celui assumer et voulu
absolument c'est un jeu de rôles
c'est un jeu de rôle et chacun était
dans son rôle
le déposer 41 mille amendements on l'a
bien vu
cc c'est interdire toute délibération
interdire tout débat au moins l'une des
vertus de l'alinéa 3 de l'article 49
c'est au moins de permettre un débat
alors c'est un il est ce qu'il est un
débat qui est court un débat qui porte
sur la question de la responsabilité
politique du gouvernement donc qui se
termine a une vocation générale mais au
moins le l'alinéa 3 de l'article permet
de ré instaurer un débat là où c'était
le cas dans cette hypothèse là où le
débat va être impossible
je trouve que l'obstruction n'est pas de
l'opposition il faut qu'on arrête de
nous dire ça médiatiquement c'est vrai
qu' on est bien placé pour le savoir
quand on s'oppose ont construit en tout
cas dans le droit constitutionnel ce
même une exigence dans certains régimes
on peut pas considérer que vouloir
empêcher comme ça un gouvernement
d'avancer c'est s'opposer ça n'est pas
ça l'opposition vers conditions
difficiles mais il n'ya pas pardon il ya
vraiment cet argument anti démocratique
la simulation avec l'article 16 mai
c'est un argument enfin c'est un une
arme absolument démocratique puisque ça
permet d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement qui prend qui prend cyrice
alors bien sûr effectivement lorsqu'on a
la majorité la majorité va pas renverser
son gouvernement mais enfin c'est quand
même une responsabilité qui est prise
par par le gouvernement donc ça il faut
pas l'oublier
et puis il ya un deuxième point si c'est
que les une révision de la constitution
en 2008 et ça on l'oubli parce qu on
cite souvent michel rocard il l'utilisé
28 fois ci je crois et depuis 2008 on ne
peut plus l'utiliser -que que deux fois
donc par par session j'entends par
session parlementaire
donc les hypothèses d'utilisation de
cette arme sont extrêmement restreinte
aujourd'hui on peut plus en faire
l'usagé qu'on faisait
nous gouvernons avant probablement alors
il va y avoir la navette
ça va passer au sénat ça va revenir à
l'assemblée alors là probablement on
peut réutiliser le 49 3 go retour c'est
l'utilisation non justement c'est ce
qu'il sait ce qu'il fait chaque c'est
probablement ce qui va se passer veut
non politiquement un silo à grains on le
sera dans la même session est sûre même
taxé sur sa succession
bref les docks il ya plus de 200 sites
et dans ses positions de tête sachant
quand même en jeu mais effectivement on
peut pas l'utiliser devant le sénat
puisque on ne le peut pas nice n est pas
renverser le gouvernement ne peut pas
l'utiliser sur le texte de loi organique
qui risque quand même de l'amp est très
un peu mais un texte
il a grillé sa cartouche et c'est le
projet de loi ordinaire donc le projet
de loi organique ne pourrait pas être
concerné par le 45t mondial de volley en
forme des retraites une loi ordinaire et
noir yannick et si certes ok par le
conseil constitutionnel
qu'est ce qui se passe ça c'est après le
vote de l'après vol et de toute façon a
priori ok c'est à dire les dispositions
ont frappés de censure ne pourront pas
nouveau en train mais il n'y a pas eu
est-ce qu'il me semble qu'elle ait une
procédure nouvelle qui permettait
d'accélérer les débats depuis longtemps
figuré ça réduit le nombre de navettes
tous les moyens ont été utilisés
effectivement d'abord faire que les
choses aillent rapidement d'accord donc
selon vous c'est pas un déni de
démocratie selon jean-charles absolument
tout à fait deux
pour gagner vos dons mais c'est tout à
fait démocratique je vais après si vous
faire goûter pour d'autres députés début
de la représentation nationale s'exprime
sais très bien que tu te fait logique
s'est prêtée faut préciser ya il ya 2 2
cas dans lequel tu sais utiliser le
premier c'est quand tu es en effet le le
gouvernement si ce qu'est une
obstruction de la part de l'opposition
et le deuxième cas c'est quand on a ce
qu'était le cadre de roccat quand on a
une majorité relativement faibles et
pour elle voilà pour éviter qu'une
motion de censure soit soit soit voté
contre le gouvernement pour ressouder un
peu la majorité
c'est peut-être sur un point kg et qui
me semble un peu discutable sa patte en
usage du 49-3 qui me paraissait un peu
attendu de toute façon mais c'est
peut-être la communication
gouvernementale ce samedi midi
oui on est censé se réunir pour le plus
grand nombre
là c'est vraiment mais on a vraiment
dégainer sky 3 pour la première fois
parce que normalement c'est quelque
chose d'un peu attendu d'un petit projet
nuit
il faut rappeler que le produit choisi
un sommet avec les virus non mais c'est
vrai que généralement haussier que
généralement quand quand il va y avoir
l'utilisation du 49 3 il ya une réunion
d'analystes et annonce que le plant et
là c'est vrai que l'annoncé ait été
faite juste un site communication et de
sucre alors donc le césar de la mauvaise
foi est a prévenu jean-luc mélenchon
notamment non mais où juste un jeu
chacun est dans son rôle j'ai finalement
entraîné avec eux comment ça allait mais
venir mais là ils deviennent surenchère
dans les mots enfin ont fini voilà il y
avait tagué sur la fac
hier ou avant-hier le 49-3 tu sais rien
que ça nos villes on a vu avec quelqu'un
dont bâillonner un bayonnais encore
c'est pas voilà c'est pas un décès enfin
jusqu'à preuve du contraire le 49-3 n'a
tué personne je parlais de césar parce
que ça a été c'est peut-être le débat de
la semaine je sais pas si vous avez
assisté à cette soirée assez surréaliste
nous avons insisté non enfin j'en ai vu
de regarder entendu parler non pas le
set débat de la semaine
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que la grande famille
ici des mac ou de la peine c'est un peu
déchiré pendant cette soirée soirée
assez particulier assez étonnante c'est
surréaliste maintenant il ya le à mon
sens de la grande perdante de cette
cérémonie c'est florence foresti qui
était quand même jusqu'à cette date tous
les humoristes drôle enfin mais qui la
fin d'un discours totalement fin
grossesse à la niña
il ya deux étapes se dire que le
lendemain et le surlendemain tout le
monde avait trop de trouver formidable
et puis après deux jours plus tard ça
qu'on pensait à puis après on a rêvé des
mal classés il s'entendre 230000 euros
on comprend que oui parce que sinon si
si vraiment je pense que c'est canal qui
soit qui était un peu furieux qu'elle
ait abandonné la serre et veut dire oui
mais sur quelle fatigue et fait fuiter
le le montant du café mais c'est vrai
que c'est quand même pas très cohérent
et même de la part d' adèle haenel qui
s'en va ces postures tout à fait
désagréable si florence foresti n'avais
pas envie de côtoyer
les gens qui ont voté pour polanski et
ses sites tous à la dégoûte pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle a pris ses 130 mille
euros pour bourbon pour faire son sketch
en même temps le sabbat aucun courage là
dedans je dis non mais attaquer
quelqu'un qui n'était pas facile ce
n'est pas un rôle facile quand même ses
dires il aurait fallu peut-être plus de
talents plus d'intelligence plus de
recul et là ça a été vraiment à celle où
le degré pas aux fuites traité polanski
donald appelé atchoum enfin je veux dire
je vois pas du tout ce que ça roule
c'est un peu la limite et de mépris ono
band arrogance je trouve qu'elle n'était
pas dans l'équipe qui était attendu
parce que le courage c'était de venir et
c'est un courage qui est qui a été pris
mais c'est vrai que la prestation la
donne à croire que l'attitude et était
pas forcément la bonne en tout cas
hurler avec la meute avec les loups fin
je le trouve ça totalement répugnant et
le et en rond je tire mon chapeau à des
comédiens avions extraordinaire avec son
jean dujardin lambert wilson au maire
mulsanne kyi qui défend polanski sentent
sans défendre le polanski le violeur
mais défend la personnalité de polanski
le cinéaste renonce à qui personne du
roi de france qui n'a jamais baissé ce
que je ne précise pas et que de la part
de lambert wilson extrêmement courageux
parce que ça va à linverse de l'opinion
publique et qu' il sort un film il joue
deux goals la même semaine il prend le
risque quand même de se mettre à dos une
partie des populations et ils osent
aller contre vents et marées c'est
pareil pour fanny ardant qui a fait un
texte magnifique mais hélas on est quand
même bien il vient dans l'intelligence
dans le courage et c'est alors que
virginie despentes et et florence
foresti on est dans l'eure mais elle a
pu vous parler de wilson parler d'eux
des acteurs qui ont cure des fondus
polanski est-ce qu'il ya pas une
fracture générationnelle moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya vraiment ça c'est
à dire que tous les gens d'à peu près 50
ans considère que ponce qui s'est
d'abord un grand réalisateur et tous les
gens de 30 ans considère que c'est
d'abord un buveur polanski c'est d'abord
un type qui est présumé innocent le le
le c'est un principe fondamental est
donc le la personne qui agit en flagrant
délit elle est présumée innocente
bon là c'était même pas le cas y'a pas
de flagrant délit et c'est donc le débat
de mon point de vue doit se concentrer
uniquement là dessus
nul n'a se substituer à la justice qui
est seul légitime pour condamner le
droit est a déjà été condamnée qui les
mangent et lui n'est toujours pas j'ai
lu et l'apa il a pas il a fait que 42
jours de prison et c'est insuffisant et
se sont se tait d'aidé qui donne enfin
des gens qui disent mais de quel droit
de deux quêtes de quel droit ces riches
dont soi même en petit procureur au
petit pied puisque on se saluait avec
les pieds tout à l'heure pour considérer
qu'un tel n'a pas fait à cette prison
etc
nous n'avons pas nous substituer à
l'autorité judiciaire si ce type est
coupable et bien voilà alors il ya des
des procédures qui sont en cours
d'autres qui sont prescrites
mais enfin c'est cauchemardesque
on vit dans un alors je dis cela donc je
suis pas complice meilleur jour des
violeurs je suis je suis moins violent
c'est ça qui est terrible c'est qu'on y
est on est soumis de choisir son camp et
si on est avec polanski on est dans le
camp des violeurs je suis quand même
content quand les antisémites
c'est bien compliqué
herman du débat mis là où effectivement
on présente les choses en deux
catégories qui interdisent la pensée
vraiment d'être subtil et ils pouvoir d
tout argument un peu nuancé qu'elisa
après tout le monde dira près d'où il ya
le droit il faudrait peut-être le
respecter il est difficilement audible
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est terrible
il est difficilement audible mais moi ce
que je veux qu'ils soient difficilement
audible peu m'importe
mais ce qui m'importe c'est que on ne
m'empêche pas de dire ce que je pense et
qu'on ne m'empêche pas d'aller voir un
film que je souhaite aller voir c'est
tout que les personnes qui le souhaitent
ne s'y rendent pas moi ça me gêne pas ce
film a fait trois millions et demi ou 8
millions d'entrées oui il est il faut
dire que les boks et le vote d'aider des
gens qu'il faut laisser la profession a
simplement c'est tous les gens qui ont
voté qu'une pour les nominations donc à
peu près 5000 personnes qu'on ne vienne
pas me censurer ou considérez que je
suis un violeur parce que je vais voir
ce film c'est tout parce que sinon enfin
rien n'est plus possible et il faut tout
brûler brûlons toutes les oeuvres
brûlons tous les monuments et c'est le
summum du ridicule étant atteint par le
livre culture
là c'est vraiment vers qui se permet de
dire avant le avant la soirée ben on va
écouter ci se serait même te fait mal
c'est en décerné un prix à polanski
l'hôpital un maître chien
bonjour essayez-vous j'arrive un peu
comme vous arrivez enchère
ce moment parce que les arrivées de
radio classique déjà présenté ce matin
encore la revue de presse et et non vous
ne vous ne savez pas parler aujourd'hui
c'est ça j'en ai parlé tous les jours
vous allez me parler tous les jours vous
avez parlé notamment de 7,7 tribune de
virginie despentes qui était assez
incroyable
je cite je suis un petit peu ce qu'elle
veut ce qu'elle dit que l'académie des
césars ellis polanski meilleur
réalisateur de l'année c'est grotesque
que c'est insultant mais ça n'est pas
surprenant quand tu confies un budget de
plus de 25 millions à un mec pour faire
un téléfilm
le message est dans le budget est-ce
qu'il faut prendre de l'argent le nom de
la liberté
moi je crois qu'il ya quand même un
moment où touche le fond quand on est
forcément dans deux extrêmes
à partir du moment où on est on entend
défendre une position c'est à dire que
florence foresti sur son sketch a été
considérée comme antisémite
à partir du moment où elles avaient donc
utiliser le terme app shop qui souhaite
franchement pas des masses mais après on
est entre amis on est en train de
toucher vraiment le fond je pense parce
que du coup chacun condamne l'hôte de
faire partie d'un camp qui sont quand
même des termes très grave
des termes qui correspondent et là je te
je te rejoins complètement à des
qualifications juridiques qui
nécessitent des condamnations qui
nécessite quand même d'approfondir et de
réfléchir sur le fond et soit on est
pour
et dans ce cadre là en fait quelque part
on fait partie du côté des violeurs soit
on est content dans ce calendrier
antisémite on est vraiment en train de
son extrait misé 1 mes valeurs au 18è ce
qui est quand même
voilà du coup si coupable est le
préalable à tout ça c'est que si
finalement romane polanski a pu faire
ces films c'est que déjà au préalable il
n'est pas en prison où il n'aurait pas
pu il réalise
donc peut-être que le vrai problème est
là c'est à dire sur le fait de réfléchir
comment en france maintenant on peut
faire évoluer comme adèle haenel l'avait
très correctement dit la culture pour
que finalement les femmes soit entendue
et que ce nouveau siècle soit celui de
la libération de la parole et peut-être
d'un nouveau droit pénal pourquoi pas
mais dans ce cadre là à l'heure actuelle
il a pu réaliser ce film qui existe un
bon film sur lequel on n'a pas besoin de
stigmatiser toute la nouvelle vague qui
est censé arriver principe même de la
nouveauté c'est d'avoir pas de
rétroactivité dans le temps il ya quand
même un vrai problème de temps la
prescription il est censé apaiser les
esprits justement pour dire ce que le
droit n'a pas pu régler au moment où
c'était possible de le régler et bien il
faut arrêter d'en parler donc il ya
peut-être un moment où maintenant il
faut qu'on réfléchisse à ce qu'on veut
pour l'avenir mais en restant un peu
apaisées sur ce qui s'y passe est une
société très drôle lyon survenus ce que
vous dites n'est pas un problème de
génération alors que je pense que vous
parle et défend les autres intentions de
le vrai problème c'est que les gens de
30 ans n'ont jamais vu un film de
polanski c'est surtout ça qui compte et
c'est juste du fait divers vous diviser
toute la presse dont vous savez tout sur
tout mais vous êtes oeuvre d'objectivité
quand vous faites toujours moi pas
toujours est-ce que vous avez une
position là dessus par exemple des
observations déjà j'ai trouvé étonnant
finalement d'avoir obtenu l'absence de
polanski tout a été fait pour qu'il soit
à la campagne d'intimidation
la passion avant la cérémonie et en fait
il a été omniprésent
donc c'est assez curieux déjà là on est
dans une forme directe en ligue 2 on
fait tout pour qu'ils viennent pas on
on prie le ciel pour qu'il n'ait pas de
prix il a douze nominations et on en
parle pendant toute la soirée tout en
disant mais c'est scandaleux de le
priver donc faudrait secoue voudrais
savoir ce qu'on veut et ce qu'on veut
qu'il soit là même virtuellement ou est
ce qu'on veut qu'il ne soit pas là la
deuxième chose c'est que c'est une sale
soirée ratée mais globalement les soirée
des césars sont ratés gc ca qui a fait
le plus d'audience du coup oui d'autant
de monde ici va peut-être se passer
quelque chose est en fait pourquoi c'est
raté parce que les comédiens font du
cinéma c'est à dire que il joue au
comédien engagé
c'est à dire que il faut qu'ils arrivent
sur la scène avec la densité de gens qui
pensent et qui ont un point de vue
politique et je suis pas sûr que la
distribution des prix soit le lieu de la
prise de parole politique parce que
quand c'était pas polanski s'était
insulté le ministre de la culture
quand il était pas insulter mise la
culture s'était levé le poing au nom des
intermittents du spectacle quand c'était
pas les intermittents du spectacle
c'était rebelote les femmes et c'est
donc l'utilisation des césars comme
tribune c'est connu depuis toujours
simplement en fait les gens ça les amuse
pas c'est tout simplement alors là pour
le coup il ya eu un papier je sais plus
où de raphaël enthoven assez marrant qui
a dit finalement le grand vainqueur de
cette soirée c'est le théâtre parce
qu'ils étaient si on nous disait si on
nous disait six jours après qu'en fait
c'était du théâtre
imaginez imaginer qu'ils aient tous rôle
ce serait ce serait fantastique parce qu
on se dirait elle est partie le bras en
l'air peut-être qu'elle le pensait mais
bon
la compter les noirs dans la salle
c'était très drôle et c'était pas très
drôle mais en même temps c'était bien vu
parce que ça a créé des tensions
imaginez qu'on nous dise une semaine
après en fait c'était du théâtre c'est
c'était un hommage du cinéma au t1 ce
serait marrant bon maintenant au delà de
ça c'est très compliqué on dit il faut
pas séparer l'homme de l'oeuvre très
bien enfin c'est difficile de séparer
l'homme de l'oeuvre quand vous êtes
censé récompenser l'homme sur scène on
peut pas on peut pas et par dali nahdi
accrue des années que son écrivain
préféré c'est essayer c'est digne les
bains alors c'est son droit
non mais donc elle sépare bien l'oeuvre
de céline son cas est réglé depuis
longtemps face au lean le temps a passé
en plus ils sont en droit tout à fait
l'idée de dire à moi je dis pas céline
parce que je me bouche le nez est un
truc de la nouvelle génération
c'est pour ça que je dis là il ya une
scène une fracture générationnelle
fracture générationnelle parce que pour
les gens de ma génération en plus moi je
m'appelle david habib qui redonnerait un
peu je suis un grand dadais de s'en
mêler pour paraphraser sarkozy a quand
il disait je suis un petit français de
sang mêlé ils en ont rien à les
gens de notre génération moi ça a été un
bouquet chez lui à 18 ans à aucun moment
je me suis dit je vais pas lire parce
qu'il est antisémite
je savais que c'était un mec compliqué
et j'ai lu le voyage aux boules réduit à
pieds joints
mais aujourd'hui il y a un côté il faut
lire les choses ou aborder les heures
avec un code pénal dans une main et puis
un code moral dans l'autre c'est
compliqué quand même un mort elle même
et le j'ai l'impression qu'ils aient
aussi une évolution du féminisme qui va
un peu vers la guerre contre des hommes
quand même non votre part qui revient
qui revient presque les origines et les
milices de son un peu celle là mais mais
c'est vrai que la falaise là il ya
tendance quand même à considérer que les
hommes sont dans le sens des prédateurs
pas tous blancs 0 et au delà de 50 ans
c'est pas la mode aux femmes aux futures
femmes aux jeunes femmes de dire que
finalement maintenant soit on est un
couteau entre les dents pour montrer
qu'être une femme est un combat soit
finalement on risque de retomber dans
les minorités visibles
il faut que l'égalité elle se fasse par
le fait peut-être que changer les choses
ça peut aussi être intelligent il ya des
discours qui sont en train d'évoluer
c'est une belle chose que ça se fasse
dans ce climat de violence finalement à
mon avis dessert encore plus le discours
et c'est ça qui est quand même
dramatique
alors là dessus et ouais je voudrais
dire deux choses la première c'est que
j'ai pris une leçon par ma fille a trois
jours parce que j'étais dans quelque
chose qui fleure bon elles vont un peu
loin bon enfin je temporise est alors ma
fille et il me dit mais on voit que tu
prends plus le métro moi chaque fois que
je prends le métro via m'emmerder et
j'ai eu ce réflexe complètement débile
jeudi mais défend toi et puis au moment
où je disais ça je me suis rendu compte
traiter complètement crétin parce qu'en
fait c'est par aux femmes de se défendre
si vous voulez le coup de gueule
le fait de taper du poing sur la table
c'est qu'à un moment donné quand vous
prenez le métro vous fait siffler dans
la rue vous en avez marre et c'est pas
aux femmes de se défendre ou avoir des
comportements ou des remakes de sens et
c'est aux mecs de changer mais comme ils
comprennent pas les femmes soit obligée
d'élever le temps ça c'est la première
chose et puis la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il faut à chaque fois se dire quand
ces groupes radicaliser quand cette
tribune violente nounou earth et moi
aussi j'ai pas aimé vraiment la tribune
de death pente et en même temps c'était
du despote c'est de la littérature avant
d'être un point de vue politique je
pense c'est que les radicaux des façons
c'était autre chose
la meilleure chose que les faits dans
les règles rappelé texte radicaux y est
les textes radicaux d'hyères wii sera en
service et aux gens tranquilles
d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire si ma fille
elle peut prendre la pilule aujourd'hui
si ma fille aussi mes filles peuvent se
balader à peu près tranquille un peu
partout six centres étaient également en
classe par le professeur c'est parce que
avant-hier où il ya des années vous avez
d adèle haenel et vous avez des despotes
qui ont dit ça suffit ou d aulas qui
aurait créé j'accuse ou désolation des
cris j'accuse mais je crois que cela
n'est pas en cause dans cette histoire
non non non non non non mais c'est aussi
un texte mais l'ont certaine façon le
texte des stands il est outrancier il
est parfois gratuit
il est parfois méchant il ya une mise il
ya une semaine
oui transfigure qui que tu pourras
absolument aller au fond c'est un
rapport de pouvoir leur amère et ça met
un rapport du national assimile les
hommes au pouvoir et le bourg à la
domination
c'est la vieille rengaine de bourdieu
dominant dominé avec une lecture comme
ça du monde c'est 01 informatique donc
voilà c'est la société dans laquelle on
va se dire est ce qu'on dit et tout à
l'heure il faut choisir ce qu'on est
dans le camp des violeurs ou des
antisémites et on est obligé de blancs
ou noirs d'être manichéen et que la
position pas dans tous les domaines
d'ailleurs dans le gender montcourt
d'heureuses on vous propose 18 juin
différentes vues entre les v8 russe oui
enfin là des numéros vous avez
l'alignement s'il voulait pas la face et
quoi ouais donc du nom beat lennon
binaire dans les oueds ans les gens qui
refusent de choisir entre les deux les à
jour ci soit quand albin michel 3 non 3
de saison il me semble je ne sais pas si
c'est en allemagne mais s'il ya un état
dans lequel s'est reconnue je retombe un
peu tiré sur le féminin je pense que
c'est dommage justement que que ce
discours du féministe deviennent les
femmes contre les hommes parce que ce
qu'on veut obtenir c'est l'égalité des
droits c'est l'égalité de pouvoir se
balader dans le métro justement un peu
tranquillement
c'est vrai que ça nous changerait et je
pense que ça c'est un combat pour juste
être à côté et avec et être les mêmes
mais si on est l'un contre l'autre
finalement on repère complètement notre
débat et je pense qu'on n'est plus
entendue de la bonne manière et moi
c'est juste un petit peu ça qui me gêne
c'est il faut peut-être de la violence
il faut que les mentalités changent je
crois que le discours qu'a eue adèle
haenel quand elle a quant elle a parlé a
été vraiment un discours de civilisation
elle a été très loin et je crois que
c'était une bonne chose mais que
maintenant ça devienne forcément un
parti pris avec une hostilité contre
tout ce qui se fait de l'autre côté va
devenir une forme d'ostracisation qui va
encore nous faire perdre du temps et ça
ans je trouve ça dommage
il est rappelé aux ce n'était pas
nouveau il ya pas que la condamnation
les réseaux sociaux pour les paroles il
ya aussi le droit tout et compagnie face
à ça apporte
suis je moi je me suis père de trois
filles j'ai faim j'ai ça conscient à
l'esprit ça apporte de trucs mais s'est
dans le même temps c'est cauchemardesque
de beaufs de livrer au pilori fins et
c'est de deux siècles de siècle de de
progrès de raffinement intellectuel
juridiques judiciaires qui sont foutus à
la poubelle oui c'est pas cool pour le
coup le féminisme est pas en cause
exclusivement sur ce thème notamment de
donner le change
je veux parler suez pour le coup média
suis à des lynchages dans tous les
domaines où la la présomption
d'innocence et est en cause mais mais je
crois une fête plus que à chaque fois
que les femmes se sont rebellés on leur
a toujours reproché de ne pas le faire
comme il fallait et souvent c'était des
hommes ou c'étaient des gens qui étaient
partisans de la stabilité et du statu
quo alors les femmes elles disent mais
alors on a été très très méchante
il faut se rebeller comment vous nous
dites de fer ou et c'est bon on n'exige
pas ça de la cgt ni de sud ni de
solidaires quand ils veulent faire des
dépositions et c'est quelqu'un qui est
plutôt combien conservateur qui vous le
dit mais je dois dire que ce que m'a dit
ma fille mardi m'a secoué basse et bien
oui c'est bien de ces personnes qui font
ces actions elles sont vertueuses mais
c'est qu'on a parfois le sentiment que
c'est pas le message qui est important
mais qu'au contraire le message est
utilisé pour se mettre en scène et pour
faire du buzz
oui c'est ça qui est vous
années 80 quand acteurs c'est vrai que
c'est violent si un réacteur qui s'était
ultraviolents regarder 20 ans ont fait
douter videmanette géant se dit sans
acteur qu'est ce qui se serait passé et
ce qu'ils ont pas accélérer les choses
donc la reine la radicalité
d'aujourd'hui fera peut-être le progrès
de demain et et nos enfants s'en
réjouiront où nos petits-enfants
en un mot puisque vous êtes là alors
donc à la revue de presse de radio
classique lui vous êtes le week-end
aussi non alors je n'enregistre le
mercredi une émission de deux fois trois
heures pour le samedi et le dimanche
qu'ils s'appellent votre week-end radio
classique et en fait on écoute ça moi je
parle je passe les disques et c'est très
agréable c'est quelque chose que je
connaissais pas face à déjà si ce que je
connaissais pas et en fait il faut être
il faut être steward ou hôtesse de l'air
un peu et amener les places c'est tout
un art enfin plus c'est toi et c'est une
émission de ça les hommes aussi peuvent
c'est tout un art c'est une impasse et
les remercie beaucoup
jean baptiste du club stéphane rousseau
et jean charles lajoie 10 et à très vite
pour un nouveau parfum
[Musique]